D
THIS JUST IN SUPREME COURT.
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE CLARENCE
THOMAS HAS NOW ISSUED A
STATEMENT THE FIRST COMMENT FROM
THOMAS OR THE SUPREME COURT
AFTER THE REPORT BY PROPUBLICA
LAYING OUT HOW JUSTICE THOMAS
AND HIS WIFE WENT ON MANY TRIPS
OVER THE YEARS PAID FOR BY HIS
FRIEND AND BIG REPUBLICAN DONOR
, HARLAN CROWN AND IMPORTANTLY,
DID NOT DISCLOSE THAT IN ANY
DISCLOSURES. ARIANA VOGUE IS
BACK WITH US WITH MORE ON THE
STATEMENT ON WHAT IS THE JUSTICE
SAYING NOW? RIGHT YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT. THE FIRST TIME
WE HEAR FROM HIM AFTER THE
RELEASE OF THAT BOMBSHELL REPORT
THAT REALLY DETAILED OVER THE
YEARS THAT HE TOOK THESE TRIPS
TO PLACES LIKE NEW ZEALAND,
INDONESIA ON PRIVATE YACHTS,
PRIVATE JETS NEVER DISCLOSED IT
, AND IT WAS ALL PAID FOR BY
THIS MEGA REPUBLICAN DONOR NAMED
HARLAN CROW. I'M GOING TO READ
YOU THE STATEMENT, AND IT'S KIND
OF LONG, BUT KEEP IN MIND. WE DO
NOT USUALLY HEAR STATEMENT LIKE
THIS FROM CLARENCE THOMAS. HE
SAID. HARLAN AND CATHY CROWE ARE
AMONG OUR DEAREST FRIENDS AND WE
HAVE BEEN FRIENDS FOR OVER 25
YEARS AS FRIENDS DO. WE HAVE
JOINED THEM ON A NUMBER OF
FAMILY TRIPS DURING THE MORE
THAN A QUARTER CENTER. WE HAVE
KNOWN THEM EARLY IN MY TENURE AT
THE COURT, I SOUGHT GUIDANCE
FROM MY COLLEAGUES AND OTHERS IN
THE JUDICIARY AND WAS ADVISED
THAT THIS SORT OF PERSONAL
HOSPITALITY FROM CLOSE PERSONAL
FRIENDS WHO DID NOT HAVE
BUSINESS BEFORE THE COURT WAS
NOT RE PORTABLE. I HAVE
ENDEAVORED TO FOLLOW THAT
COUNSEL THROUGHOUT MY TENURE AND
HAVE ALWAYS SOUGHT TO COMPLY
WITH THE DISCLOSURE GUIDELINES.
THESE GUIDELINES ARE NOW BEING
CHANGED AS THE COMMITTEE OF THE
JUDICIAL CONFERENCE RESPONSIBLE
FOR FINANCIAL DISCLOSURES FOR
THE ENTIRE FEDERAL JUST
JUDICIARY. JUST THIS PAST MONTH
ANNOUNCED NEW GUIDANCE AND IT IS
, OF COURSE, MY INTENT TO FOLLOW
THIS GUIDANCE IN THE FUTURE.
WHAT'S INTERESTING ABOUT THAT
STATEMENT IS HE WANTS TO MAKE
CLEAR THAT HARLAN CROW HAD NO
BUSINESS BEFORE THE COURT. HE
WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT THAT BUT AS
YOU KNOW, THIS COMES, THIS STORY
COMES AS THE COURT ITSELF IS
UNDER THIS HARSH SPOTLIGHT. SO
MANY PEOPLE ARE BEGINNING TO
THINK THAT IT'S BEGINNING TO
LOOK LIKE ANOTHER POLITICAL
BRANCH AFTER WE'VE HAD THOSE
CONTENTIOUS CONFIRMATION
HEARINGS OF LATE AND AS THE
JUSTICES HAVE BEEN MORE AND MORE
ON THOSE HOT BUTTON ISSUES
DIVIDING ALONG THESE FAMILIAR
IDEOLOGICAL LINES, SO THIS COMES
AT A TIME THOMAS WANTED TO
RESPOND VERY QUICKLY. AND HE'S
TRYING TO EXPLAIN WHY HE DIDN'T
REPORT THESE TRIPS BEFORE THOSE
ETHICS RULES WERE CHANGED. AND
AS YOU SAID IT IS, IS RARE TO
HEAR A STATEMENT FROM ONE OF THE
JUSTICES IN RESPONDING TO